Jamie Boyd congratulations you guys are
in the final round of this Christmas
themed competition now we're sending you
back to your home for just to recreate
this iconic weapon from history
the 1796 British light Cavalry saber
[Music]
pre-testing the 1796 British light
Cavalry saber
silver sword means something that you
should be able to use in horseback
supposed to be light so when you think
about moving with this it's a heavy
sword and you're on Horseback you take
that into consideration can I wheel this
while riding a horse and when you're
going with speed you're able to cut and
find out what does a curved blade do
this way and what kind of damage does it
do in motion so the media is a big
carcass it's skin
can a slashing weapon cut all the way
through or he's just going to chop or is
it definitely going to be devastating
with the single strike the 1796 English
light Cavalry sword was first used by
British dragoons and Napoleonic Wars
unlike the suddenly boat French Cavalry
Sabers of the era the English version
had a deep curve whose width increased
as it reached the tip although this
design weakened the Blade's thrusting
capabilities it made every slash heavier
and more brutal
designed to inflict maximum damage
during large melees on the battlefield
the saber had the ability to remove
heads and limbs with a single stroke
the light Cavalry sword is the weapon of
the traditional wooden Christmas
Nutcracker and can be seen at the iconic
soldier's side in the latest film
adaptation of the Tchaikovsky nutcracker
ballet the Nutcracker in the four realms
ready
we use a lot of pig carcasses because
the pig is the closest thing to the
human body I mean we're going straight
against skin over here
it allows us to really get and see the
cuts there's no hair on the pig so when
it's weapon against skin you really see
how it lacerates how it punctures and
how you can see the wound Channel
when I look at it I go wow that's a
deeper cut than that of the other guy so
it gives me a great basis of comparison
remember when I'm doing these tests it's
not about my skill it's about me letting
the weapon do its own damage
one thing though you know it's all about
the respect of the animal at the end of
the test I was about to death and say
thank you and of course every medium or
meats and fishes are always donated to
the wildlife conservation so I don't
feel so bad I know that we're feeding
the wolves
all right gentlemen good luck we'll see
you in four days
my name is Jamie Chandler
nothing that's probably going to be my
Edge in this competition because having
three hours to make a knife is how I
learned how to make a knife
the goal today is to just get to stand
my ability put together and then stretch
out the bill as much as I possibly can
so tomorrow I can really break it home
there it is
I officially burned my fillet into two
pieces and I am definitely falling
behind on the clock I started my day off
with 70 of yesterday's Billet
one stick for whatever reason I could
not get the medals to fuse
my small failures are compounding into
catastrophes
it's Do or Die time bail on the sand
mine
I have to start over again I go in my
junk pile and I find a nice two inch bar
of tool steel very disappointed I have
to give up on my original sand my
construction but I have to make
something that I can actually finish I
don't even have the sword blade yet my
emergency plan is I'm taking two pieces
of mild steel and making us sand my
Billet on the Tang end of my carbon
steel Billet in order to be able to draw
it out long enough
foreign
I cannot believe this thing just cracked
on me I've used the technique before and
it works but I'm running out of time I
can't just mess around with something's
not gonna work so I abandoned it and I
just grab a leaf spring
pressure is really hard
bye I'm gonna finish I'm either gonna
turn something in that I can be proud of
or I'm not showing up and I'm I'm
showing up I'm gonna finish my blade and
I'm gonna go there and show them what
I'm made of
Mama didn't raise no quitter
my name is Boyd Ritter I'm a mechanical
engineer from White Rock New Mexico at
home my son likes to come in and do the
will Willis countdown every time he's
tired of me being in the garage by
myself
I'm really excited about Christmas and
hopefully I get a really good Christmas
present at ten thousand dollars we got
all my scene
[Music]
bring it up to two
I start drawing out my Billet everything
on the power hammer is working excellent
so with the time I have left I'm gonna
get it cut we're gonna go Monastery with
the 5160. we're just gonna go all out
and move as fast as we can this is a
really light weapon it needs to stay a
lightweight I do have a lot to get done
and a short amount of time
luckily I have my own personal will
Willis here so at some point today I
will get a countdown and let me know
when all of this is done
I'm gonna put Christmas on this handle I
think it's cool
[Music]
good job buddy
bladesmiths welcome to the kill test
keeping with this Christmas theme I'm
gonna take your weapons to deliver some
slashes and chops on this Christmas ham
Jamie up first you ready for this let's
do it
all right Jamie the first thing that I
noticed is the extreme weight
automatically I could feel the stress on
my hand it wants to fall forward now
let's talk about the blade this is a
chopper that gets work done in three
chops your weapon sir will kill thank
you
all right Boyd were you not hearing nice
because it's your turn
I don't know let's see
all right Boyd you nailed the weight
this proves that a light sharp blade is
just as deadly as a heavier sword
overall sir you're Nutcracker saber or
keto thanks
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now to test the strength
of your Sabers I will be chopping into
this ice block
Jamie you're up first you ready I am
the biggest issue I have with your blade
is its weight but for this test the
strong blade it held up good job thank
you
all right Boyd you ready I don't know
all right so boy now your Blade's still
sharp it still has a perfect Edge didn't
take any damage that way but
we did pick up a bit of a warp towards
the tip I mean it's definitely
an issue it's not so far out that it
wouldn't cut everything else is still
tight and together good job yes sir
thank you
all right blade Smith now it's time to
find out there's any Edge left in your
weapon this is the sharpness test the
Christmas tree trim
find out how sharp your edges are I will
trim this tree in the marquaida family
Christmas Tree tradition Jamie you're up
first you ready for this trim away
foreign
side and it's still heavy but on every
stroke I'm able to trim this tree
overall sir
it'll cut thank you
all right boy it's your turn are you
ready to do some Christmas tree trimming
keep it
[Music]
all right Boyd so your Edge is sharp and
the weight that you have for this I
didn't have to reset for every cut that
I did I just go up cut up cut up and cut
overall sir
little cup thanks
oh absolutely Jamie had issues with
weight I was good with weight but my
blade bent during the strength test
right now we're pretty even
so basically it's down to a heavy blade
and a Bent Blade and I am just shaking
in my boots
all right gentlemen the judges and I
have had a quick conference and they've
made their final determination about
which of you is the forge and fire
champion and who has to leave the forge
he played Smith leaving the forges
Jamie
now unfortunately Jamie your blade did
not make the cut that's because it's
very heavy and unwieldy and for that
reason I have to ask you to please leave
the forge
disappointed but I'm not surprised at
all I know how heavy my sword was I just
wish I could have done better
Boyd congratulations you are the force
and fire champion and that is the title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars Merry Christmas my friend
anything to say to the world uh Merry
Christmas all right my friend come on
over and Shake our hands
I'm really happy the way that the sword
turned out I was a little nervous when I
saw it take that bin but I couldn't ask
for a better performance out of it ten
thousand dollars is a great Christmas
gift to me yeah it's going to be
exciting my son will be off the walls
probably for the next month and a half
foreign